oh should I see you with the white girl
okay you guys are an attractive couple
she looks better than you so well done
what do you do for a living
your parents must have been terrible why
people you don't get it they want him to
be a nurse how far he fell from from the
past they were like look at some point
like you want to be an engineer maybe he
was like well I could engineered
beverages maybe you're dead my floors at
7-Eleven so you could get people drunk
to have them go to 7-Eleven at two in
the morning oh this is your fiance I see
the ring how old are you Miss how old
are you buddy God damn dog hey hold on
for dear life you know you look like you
got money not just because you're white
but I think you have a nice belt on you
seem very put together or what do you do
Miss
he's a scientist of what Mixology when
is the wedding your parents probably
trying to kick that down the line
right